the minimum wage has been a topic of
discussion during the presidential
campaign it's going to be an issue
during the Trump administration and
today for our classic interview we're
gonna dig into a classic interview with
Wayne Allyn root this is a he calls
himself a libertarian but very often he
just seems like an ideological
conservative I interviewed him in June
of 2014 the topic was the minimum wage
and we seem to have a fundamental
disconnect on even just the basic facts
of how economies work I'll leave it
there and we will get to my interview
with Wayne Allyn root from June of 2014
prepare yourselves because under Trump
there are going to be many discussions
like what we're about to see here back
on the program today is Wayne Allyn root
he is the 2008 Libertarian Party vice
presidential nominee American politician
entrepreneur political commentator also
author of the forthcoming book the
murder of the middle class and he's here
today to talk about the minimum wage
Wayne I don't want to summarize your
position because you do it so well
you're not thrilled with the push to
increase the middle class of the minimum
wage in the United States why is that
well because I'm a small businessman at
first of all only I know when I could
afford to pay my employees it's
impossible it's not unlikely it's not
bad it's impossible literally I can't
say it any stronger for a government
politician or a government bureaucrat to
know what I should be paying my
employees and if you do think you know
what I should pay my employees my
reaction will be I'll just fire half the
employees and that's what happens every
single time that minimum wage is
increased anywhere in the world look at
Greece look at Spain look at Italy
you've got 60 percent youth unemployment
minimum wage is basically not for poor
people for the most part it's for young
people with entry-level jobs and if
you're gonna make me raise it I just
can't afford to have that many employees
so I'll just have to fire half of them
and really government has no right to
even tell me what I could pay people in
my own private business all right so
let's put us let's put aside for a
second the government having the right
to or not because that issue is less
interesting since it's not won any
is going to be able to change that there
is a minimum wage let's talk about the
the facts on the ground of the effect of
a minimum wage increase on unemployment
we don't have to look at Greece we don't
have to look at those countries we can
look at the United States and we have
plenty of information and if you do an
analysis if you look at two decades
worth of minimum wage increases when you
look at the minimum wage increases from
1987 to 2012 52 percent of the time and
this is only looking when unemployment
was already over 7 percent okay which is
we would say we can't really tolerate
too much more unemployment 52 percent of
the time the unemployment rate went down
in the year following the minimum wage
increase four times there was no change
and then the rest that went down so at
best at best its mere chance whether the
minimum wage increase has an effect
unemployment well point out to you is
that this morning in the opening
statistics as I woke up we're that we
had one of the worst quarters in the
history of America down negative two
point nine percent GDP growth the
country's coming apart at the seams and
to ask for a minimum wage increase now
when businessmen across America like me
are dying starving going bankrupt is in
Saturday well listen win win I don't
know I don't know exactly the details of
your business and if you say you're
starving I believe you I guess yeah I've
never I didn't know you were in such
financial dire straits but you claimed
to be starving I am that's bad but
statistic is down by 60 70 percent not
10% not 5% 60 to 70 percent I have
friends who are doing worse than me our
friends who got bankrupt our friends
who've lost their homes the middle class
is being murdered and I define middle
class as small business and down what
Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne we've got
to take a step back here you can define
any of this stuff however you want you
can give us the the business disasters
that you're facing but how does that
connect with a minimum wage increase how
can you connect that because we can't
afford it it's impossible you cannot
government can't demand that I raise
wages at a time where the GDP is melting
down and there are no jobs but Wayne
that's that's a different with whether
the government can do
we agreed to not focus on that let me
get let me try a different tactic here
high school economics class I took high
school economics class and in high
school I was 16 years old I learned
about marginal propensity to consume
which tells us that if you give a little
more money to someone in the lower
middle class the likelihood that they
will spend that money reinvigorating the
economy is exponentially larger than if
that money is kept by a big corporation
or by a rich person and by and large
that did you want to comment on that
part well but hold on let me just let me
at least Libre me the whole question
someone has to pay for it so all your
prices are going up so when you raise
the minimum wage of say or the wages in
general of two million people that work
for Walmart you're what you're also
doing is raising the prices of every
item sold at Walmart no but Wayne Wayne
Wayne we have to keep this fact-based
and numerous analyses on both wal-mart
and McDonald's have shown that even if
you were to double the minimum wage paid
which would significantly affect those
businesses because they have a lot of
minimum-wage employees as you as you
admit that it would have only a slight
impact on the prices they would have to
charge to maintain equal profitability
that's the fact and the fact is that the
murder of the middle class which which
is the name of my new book is all about
the fact that politicians and big
government are in bed with big business
all you ever talk about David is the
effect on Walmart but you don't talk
about me a guy who's gonna let us talk
I'm trying to talk about that I'm trying
to talk about that whole business
creates all your jobs and it's going to
be destroyed I agree but hold on a
second Wayne first you mentioned Walmart
and when I told you you were wrong about
Walmart you said I'm trying to talk
about Walmart I want to talk about small
business so let me let me frame up a
question here and get your response will
ever show you that small business can
afford more wages higher wages for more
employees there is no such statistic let
my friends or small business men David
listen why I'm all
it's small but I'm also a small
businessman this is my small business
this program we have employees we have
staff so let me let me pause it to you
how I see this okay I have a handful of
employees as you do if the minimum wage
goes up now I don't my I'm not paying my
employees minimum wage but let's say
that their current wages went up by the
same percentage that's true that the
bright and they would so let's let's buy
into that my cost goes slightly up
you're absolutely right everybody who is
of lower and middle income has a little
bit more money the fact that we have
millions and millions of people making a
little more means that I now have
millions of people who can way more than
offset the increase to the five
employees I have and it's new customers
and we see this all over the country if
you look at San Francisco San Francisco
years ago had a much higher minimum wage
than anywhere else in the country it
applied to fast-food it applied to small
business it was across the board and
they were able to have better employment
results than the rest of the country how
do you explain that listen there's only
two things that happen when you increase
wages when government demands an
increase in wages come on the idea
whether it could work big business off
shores jobs that's why America is losing
big business jobs but hold on Wayne wait
Wayne Wayne I thought you were I thought
your concern wasn't let a big business
and small business goes out of business
you cannot as a government tell me what
wages I can afford to pay my employees
what you're doing is you're destroying
small business and it's always an
advantage to big business and by the way
that's how crony capitalism works every
single thing that has happened under the
Obama administration who supposedly is
such a fan of the little guy Oh big
business well you know what I agree with
you that in general the policies of all
presidential administrations benefit big
business that part I'm with you on but
what I want to get to is what business
specifically has gone out of business
because of an increase to the minimum
wage of pennies an hour give me a
specific business
here to give you an idea come prepared
with statistics of the names of
businesses because it doesn't exist tell
you that Spain and Italy oh my goodness
and France are completely bankrupt
completely wrecked economies when I know
I know I've seen you do so many
interviews I know that you know you're
being deceptive European countries have
been in a banking and currency crisis
that is unrelated to the minimum wage
driving individual businesses out of
business I want to make one more case
taxes and unionization and of course
that big one that I'm sure you love
david free health care you're Wayne
Wayne Wayne you're conflating unrelated
issues and you have offered you have
offered no rebuttal to the idea that is
that is a widely known basic economic
idea I learned it when I was 16 that
when you stimulate the lower and middle
class that money is spent at small
businesses at small businesses that is
an absolute stimulus of almost a
trillion dollars turned it to six of the
worst economic years in the history of
America no jobs and now negative 2.8
percent GDP ways quarter come on Wayne
this is when this is sophist tree when
this is sophist tree every respectable
economist has said that the economic
situation would have been even worse
were it not for that stimulus not just
in America but in countries all over the
world not one economist got a recession
right since the year 2000 not one poll
after poll asked economist yeah coming
in your country and since 2000 there
been multiple recessions in different
countries all around the world and zero
economists got it right
typical they're just like politicians
David they go to Harvard they study
books oh my goodness way I can't believe
you I can't believe you're doing the the
we can't trust anybody who reads books
thing okay listen Wayne you presented
what I guess our arguments
by the way you should know you should
know I graduated Columbia University and
my daughter just graduated magna [ __ ]
laude from Harvard University magna [ __ ]
laude or summa [ __ ] laude no magnet okay
alright just making sure my only point
is that going to Harvard and Columbia
does not make you a great economist
alright I think that the audience will
judge and they will research and they
will see if you look for evidence that
the minimum wage kills jobs you will
find none and Wayne has presented none
but it's always great to have him on
Wayne root the book is tell us about the
book and when people can get it the book
is the murder of the middle class it's
out July 14th available now pre-sale at
Amazon and and you'll be happy to know
David the book is not an indictment of
Democrats and liberals and Obama is an
indictment of all politicians of all
parties it's an indictment of government
government isn't here to help you
government constantly makes things worse
today's GDP results are fact and proven
results that government is not helping
anyone in this economy all right we're
gonna have Wayne back to talk about
absolutist juvenile libertarian beliefs
we're gonna need him for like an hour to
cover that topic thank you thanks Wayne